[Musica]
buonasera
ciao ciao a tutti sono giancarlo gommare
sono un ragazzo la soglia dei 30 anni e
nella vita faccio l'attore
sono molto emozionato e molto contento
di essere qui grazie grazie a voi grazie
pierfrancesco per avermi voluto io ci
tenevo tantissimo esserci questa sera
perché il tema
è molto mio odissea viaggi io uso molto
spesso queste due parole nella vita
soprattutto viaggio mi piace molto lo
faccio anche quando all'inizio di un
percorso lavorativo
auguro buon viaggio i miei colleghi a me
stesso insomma tutta la squadra
diciamo che a me piace vedermi in questo
modo come se fossi un
piccolo artigiano
che che cosa fa falli a
intagliare dei pezzi di legno creando
delle piccole barchette ogni volta e
quindi io che cosa devo fare devo
scegliere il legno
devo scegliere gli strumenti con cui
lavorarlo i colori
le decorazioni
scegliere il pacco
la confezione il fiocco con cui
abbellirlo e fino a quel momento il
viaggio è mio e del personaggio che
interpreto
e ogni volta è un bell'incontro perché
se sono lì a conoscere nuove persone a
conoscere nuove storie e nuovi viaggi
e quando tutto questo
io l'ho terminato lo porto in scena e da
quel momento il viaggio e dello
spettatore quindi mi piace insomma
attraverso i miei personaggi le storie
che racconto tramite i miei personaggi
mi piace augurare buon viaggio a tutti
voi
questa sera per me è un odissea perchè
perché sono abituato a raccontare i
viaggi di qualcun altro quindi fare il
raccontarvi il mio viaggio per me è un
po non disse a questa sera
la mia odissea diciamo così
parte
tanto tempo fa io questa sera scelgo di
parlarvi così in maniera molto
tranquilla con parole mie poi anche
utilizzando delle parole di constantino
kavafis che è un grandissimo poeta è
stato che ha scritto una bellissima
poesia nel 1911 che si chiama itaca non
a caso appunto
lui all'inizio della sua poesia dice
augura al lettore che il viaggio sia più
lungo possibile
di augurarsi che sia pieno di esperienze
pieno
di novità di avventure e io questo
facevo quando avevo 16 anni stavo sulla
finestra della mia stanza guardavo la
campagna che si estendeva insieme adesso
anche tutti i miei pensieri avevo elisa
nelle orecchie
e niente volevo urlare gridare suoniamo
di volare di abbandonare quel piccolo
paesino da cui vengo per poter
finalmente spiegare le mie ali e
affrontare questo mio viaggio
e ovviamente non immaginavo quanto
sarebbe stato difficile
non essendo consapevole però il mio
viaggio inizia all'epoca il mio viaggio
iniziava in realtà qualche anno prima
quando ero veramente molto piccolo
quando per la prima volta arrivò tra le
mie mani un copione e me lo diede una la
figlia della mia catechista niente
questo copione in mano dovevamo fare
questa recita natalizia
appunto insomma si
raccontava la nascita di gesù e io
dovevo fare re erode
ok io non volevo né fare questo ruolo
perché era il cattivo di turno quindi
poi diventato antipatico tutti gli altri
non mi piaceva e poi mi vergognavo di
salire su quel palco di dire cose non lo
so dovevo imparare tutte quelle parole
chissà se sbagliavo ero
non mi andava giù questa cosa non volevo
farla fino al momento prima di entrare
in scena poi sono percorso la navata
della chiesa sono arrivato su
quell'altare immaginate questo
bambinetto no vestito da re erode con la
sua coroncina arriva su quel palco bomba
magia
lì è successo qualcosa che io ancora non
so raccontare a parole
ed effettivamente una cosa che succede
ormai molto spesso ogni volta che
entro in una nuova storia è come se
entrassi in una bolla magica no
dove mi prendo la responsabilità di
raccontare la storia di qualcun altro
appunto ecco quella sera questo piccolo
aneddoto
io avevo un calice che era il calice con
cui il prete beve il vino durante la
funzione mi era stato detto mi
raccomando dovevo fare doveva concludere
le mie scene scagliando questo calice
sul serbo ok quindi mi è stato detto mi
raccomando intanto non fargli male poi
cerca di adagiarle di non buttarla
perché comunque un pezzo insomma
abbastanza prezioso ecco durante
quel momento non essendo più in me
diciamo così io presi questo calice è
boom lo lanciai addosso al mio compagno
che porello si dice pure male però nel
momento in cui ripercorsi la navata per
andare via
ecco in quel momento realizzai un po
quello che era successo senza capirlo
ovviamente e vedevo questa gente che si
alzava iniziava ad applaudire che mi
guardava con mossa mia madre va beh la
fiumi di lacrime ovviamente e in quel
momento era come se mi fossi reso conto
che tutta quell'energia era qualcosa che
aveva in qualche modo creato io
mi sentivo vivo quindi corsi da mia
madre di stima ma che cos'è questa cosa
cosa vuol dire fare questo e amati se
vuol dire recitare fare l'attore ok
voglio fare questo lì
ho capito che
direzione doveva prendere il mio viaggio
ovviamente sono passati degli anni ha
fatto il liceo finito il liceo
sono andata a roma ho mentito a mia
madre dicendo che andava a dormire da
un'amica per fare il provino in
accademia realtà ho viaggiato per strada
quindi anche quella è stata una bella
disse a dopo 16 ore di pullman dalla
sicilia non avevo un soldo in tasca ho
dormito
sulle scale di piazza di spagna mi hanno
svegliato i netturbini
alle 6 di mattina cacciando mi.va
però lo rifarei ovviamente ancora ancora
e ancora e arrivato quel sin dall
accademia quindi io ho iniziato il mio
percorso accademico e non vi sto a dire
quanto sia stato difficile
tutto quel periodo i primi anni a roma
io venivo da una città molto piccola
quindi già vivere in una città così
grande era
stato a stato duro perché comunque si
chiama quando dissi a mia madre io
voglio fare questo e lei tentò in
qualche modo di dirmi guarda non abbiamo
le possibilità non puoi scegliere
qualcos'altro magari rimanere in sicilia
a palermo si mamma io devo andare
perché non voglio ritrovarmi a 40 anni
dietro una scrivania
e dire che la mia vita fa schifo
io voglio andare fare questo a costo di
dormire sotto un ponte di mangiare pane
e scatolette di tonno poi una volta
arrivata a roma ho capito che manco le
scatolette di tonno mi potevo permettere
però vabbè
e da lì è iniziato tutto un percorso
abbastanza difficile pieno di sacrifici
come dicevo ci sono stati mesi e mesi
dove nel frigo avevo solo una bottiglia
di ketchup e basta quindi non è stato
così facile ma rifarei tutto ed è stata
si può dire un'odissea
ma
vissuta con leggerezza non so come dire
perché
la vera odissea che io ho otras percorso
durante la mia vita
non è esattamente
questo ha un altro nome
onestamente sono molto emozionato perché
un po la prima volta che faccio questa
cosa
la mia disse a si chiama papà
i miei genitori si sono separati quando
ero molto piccolo e io non ho mai ben
compreso la ragione e il motivo reale
per il quale mio padre avesse scelto di
separarsi anche da me
ho lottato un po tutta la vita per
inseguirlo cercarlo trovare la sua
approvazione
anche quando arrivato un po tutta la
popolarità e il successo
tutto il pubblico ha iniziato a
hama armi ad accogliermi ad apprezzarmi
a darmi quelle conferme che un po io e
tutta la vita ho cercato e stato
bellissimo ma allo stesso tempo molto
brutto e all'inizio non sapevo gestire
questa cosa perché e non capivo neanche
il perché perché dicevo ma io non mi
merito questo non ho fatto così tanto
per meritarmi questo non è abbastanza
quello che faccio perché no perché ho
tutto questo amore
non lo capivo perché in realtà l'unico
amore che cercavo non c'era
perché dico questo oggi qui
perché sicuramente è stato difficile
però
la cosa che voglio vorrei dire è che
dopo un lungo percorso dopo aver fatto
tanta analisi e bla bla bla
sono arrivato a delle consapevolezze e
queste consapevolezze
sono il risultato di
di aver
messo davanti a me le mie paure le mie
insicurezze dettate appunto da quello
che è più o meno vi ho accennato
e e ci sono andato dentro
io c'è stato un periodo della mia vita
in cui ho quasi rischiato di mandare a
monte tutto quello che avevo creato
proprio quando stavo lì è proprio quando
la gente ha iniziato a chiedermi le foto
quando
hanno iniziato a riconoscermi
lì lì ho rischiato di mandare tutto a
monte perché non riuscivo a gestire
questa cosa
e sono caduto un po giù
però andando così in fondo ho potuto
conoscere le mie paure ho potuto
conoscermi ancora più a fondo
e avendo bene in mente il mio obiettivo
è la strada da percorrere ho deciso di
rialzarmi e questa cosa mi ha piano
piano sempre di più
avvicinato a me ho capito che il vero
compagna del mio viaggio sono io mi sono
conosciuto sempre di più e sono arrivato
da marmi una cosa che per me è stata
molto difficile
da fare quest'anno è stato per me un
anno di svolta
poco pochissimo tempo fa è successa una
cosa bellissima ho ricevuto questo
premio mi hanno chiamato a venezia per
consigliamo di questo premio grazie a
meaning town next generation
sì io sono andato a venezia ritirare
quel premio però per la prima volta
nella mia vita mi sono conferito un
premio
io
e ovvero nell'esatto momento in cui
stavo davanti a quel tappeto quel
bellissimo tappeto rosso
io ho vissuto un po tutti i momenti più
brutti della mia vita un po come né
quando nei film sono il momento degli
highlights poco prima del finale di
solito fanno vedere i momenti più belli
a me è successo il contrario ho
rivissuto tutti i momenti più brutti
quando stavo dentro al bagno a pulire
con quella pezzetta piangere dimmi
perché sono qui e bla bla bla bla però
l'ultima immagine che io ho avuto prima
di aprire gli occhi e vedere quel
tappeto è stata la faccia di mio padre
allora lì in quel momento
ho aperto gli occhi
e per la prima volta nella mia vita mi
sono detto già però meriti e sono andato
questo perché ve lo dico io ve lo dico
perché perché ho passato tutta la vita
ad inseguire itaca
oggi ha smesso
perché oggi
io sono itaca
e
concludo questo mio intervento con
sicuramente delle parole più belle
rispetto a quello che utilizzato fino
adesso che sono di costantin kavafis e
sono la perfetta metafora di quello che
io vi ho appena raccontato
quando ti metterà in viaggio per itaca
dagli augurarti che la strada sia lunga
pertile in avventure e in esperienze i
lestrigoni ei ciclopi o la furia di
nettuno non temere non sarà questo il
genere di incontri se il pensiero resta
alto è un sentimento fermo guida il tuo
spirito e il tuo corpo
in ciclopi e lestrigoni non certo né nel
irato nettuno incapperai se non li porti
dentro
sé l'anima non te li mette contro
per gli augurarti che la strada sia
lunga che i mattini d'estate siano tanti
quando nei porti finalmente con che
gioia toccherai terra tool per la prima
volta negli empori fenici indugia
acquista madre perle coralli ebano e
ambre tutta merce fina anche profumi
penetranti d'ogni sorta
più profumi inebrianti che puoi va in
molte città egizie impara una quantita
di cose dai dotti sempre devi avere in
mente itaca raggiungerla sia il pensiero
costante
soprattutto non affrettare il viaggio
qualche duri a lungo per anni e che da
vecchio metta piede sull'isola to ricco
dei tesori accumulati per strada senza
aspettarti ricchezze da itaca itaca ti
ha dato il bel viaggio senza di lei mai
ti saresti messo in viaggio che
cos'altro ti aspetti
e se la trovi povera non per questo i ta
cati avrà deluso
fatto ormai savio con tutta la tua
esperienza addosso già tu avrai capito
ciò che gli da carlo vuole significare
[Applauso]